ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعيه التي تتسم بتقنيه في غايه
التعقيد تنال الكثير من الاعجاب والذهول
وفي الوقت نفسه الكثير من القلق كذلك لذلك
بعد تنظيم قطاع الذكاء الاصطناعي الاخذ في
الازدهار والنموه مطلبا ملحا الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعتزم من يكون اول جهه في العالم
ترسي اطارا قانونيا متكاملا للحد من
التجاوزات في مجال ذكاء الاصطناعي مع
حمايه الابتكار في الوقت نفسه لذلك يصوت
نواب اوروبيون على نص طموح لتنظيم قطعتك
الاصطناعي ارجو اعتمادهم مرارا او ارجئ
بسبب نقاط الجدل المحيطه بهذه التقنيه
ويطالب النواب بمعايير اكثر صرامه مع مثلا
مع ادخال حظر على انظمه التعرف على
المشاعر والغاء الاستثناءات الاستثناءات
التي تجيز لقوات الامن التعرف على الافراد
في الاماكن الع عن بعد بواسطه القياسات
الحيويه كما يعتزمون حظر جمع الصور بشكل
عشوائي على الانترنت لتطوير الخوارزميات
بدون الحصول على موافقه الاشخاص المعنيين
وفي امريكا من المتوقع ان يظهر الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه اوبل اي ان الشركه التي
تقف وراء
بشهادته في جلسه استماع اللي هي اللجنه
القضائيه الفرعيه التابعه لمجلس الشيوخ
الثلاثاء المقبل والتي ستركز على كيفيه
وضع الضمانات والرقابه على ذكاء الاصطناعي
حيث يدرس تشريعا لتنظيم الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذكاء الاصطناعي بين الضروره والخطوره
يعرف الذكاء الاصطناعي بانه محاكاه لذكاء
وسلوك البشر بفضل برامج والات ذكيه تعتمد
على خوارزميات وبرامج تعليميه
المخاوف من الذكاء الاصطناعي ترتبط
بالمعلومات المضلله وانتهاك الحقوق
المدنيه والخصوصيه اضافه الى تشكيلها
مخاطر على الامن والسلامه
راي اخر يعتبر ان الذكاء الاصطناعي سيتصدى
لكبرى التحديات في المجتمعات لكن مخاوف
كبيره تتعلق بتوقعات ان تستبدل 80% من
الوظائف بالذكاء الاصطناعي فيما البدائل
لفاقد الوظائف مجهوله
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا هنا في
الاستوديو والدكتور انس النجداوي
الاكاديمي والمستشار في اداره الاعمال
الرقميه والتقنيه اهلا بك دكتور وكذلك من
القاهره الدكتور ايمن الدهشان استشاري
والموارد البشريه ونظم الاداره الدوليه
اهلا بك دكتور واسمحولي ان ابدا هنا في
الاستوديو معك دكتور انس دكتور انس السؤال
الرئيسي في الواقع الذي يطرحه كثيرون خاصه
مع ما نسمعه وما نطلع عليه بخصوص الذكاء
الاصطناعي هل يمكن لذكاء الاصطناعي
وبالتالي او بالتحديد
ان يعوض الانسان وكل ما يملك من مهارات
وقدرات تعتقد مساء الخير طبعا
بلا شك
والكثير من التطبيقات المشاهده
المشابهه
احدثت فعلا ضجه كبيره اذ انها تمكنت فعليا
من اتمته كثير من النشاطات التي كانت
تاخذ منا ساعات واصبحت الان خلال دقائق
بسيطه وهي فعلا تحدث ثوره هي ثوره كبيره
في كثير من المجالات على مستوى التعليمي
على مستوى انشاء النصوص انشاء الملفات
بنفس الجوده بنفس جوده الى حد ما وهي احسن
تتطور بشكل سريع جدا يعني اول اصدار كان
فيه بعض الاخطاء وبعض المشاكل لكن
الاصدارات السريعه المتقاربه اصبحت تاخذ
اكثر دقه واكثر موضوعيه وفعلا هي تجتاز
الكثير من الاختبارات وهذا يؤدي الى فعلين
الى وضع علامه استفهام كبيره اين سوف يمضي
مستقبل الوظائف ومستقبل كثير من العمليات
التي نقوم بها بشكل تقليدي سوف تتغير جداء
خلينا نسال على مستقبل الوظائف طالما حاضر
معنا الدكتور ايمن دهشان استشاري الموارد
البشريه دكتور هل هناك خوف على مستقبل
الوظائف سنتحدث فيما بعد باكثر تفصيل على
الايجابيات والسلبيات فيما يخص ولكن هل
هناك خوف حقيقي على الوظائف على وظائفنا
على وظائف من يتابعون
خليني طبعا في
اتفضل دكتور طيب خليني في البدايه ارحب
بحضرتك وارحب بالجميع نحن الان في عصر
التطور التكنولوجي وعصر التكنولوجيا وعصر
الثوره الصناعيه الخمسه
وهذا الجيل بيحتاج الى المزيد من الوظائف
ستنتهي كافه الوظائف التقليديه يمكن شات
جي تي بي فقط دكتور دكتور ايمن دكتور انس
هنا يقول لك نحن في اطار الثوره
التكنولوجيه الرابعه وليس الخامسه سبقتنا
بمرحله دكتور ايمن
لا يعني احنا على قدم على قدام من الثوره
الصناعيه الخامسه يعني احنا رايحين لها
ولكن خليني اقول لحضرتك ان احنا امام يعني
دايما سؤال هل التكنولوجيا هتلغي الوظائف
الحاليه اللي موجوده لا احنا بنتطور
الوظائف بتتطور الوظائف بتتغير طبقا
للاحتياجات اللي احنا محتاجينها النهارده
شات بقى النهارده بيستخدم في تحليل
البيانات في البحث في النشر في التسويق في
العديد من الامور حتى الامور الاجتماعيه
بدا ان هو يتدخل فيها وبدا ان هو يبقى له
مساحه كبيره من
المهام والوظائف التي يقوم بها ففي الاوان
التي نعيش فيها الان كيف نتواكب مع هذه
التكنولوجيا الجديده كيف يكون لدى
المجتمعات العربيه نصيب في هذا التطوير
كيف يكون من الاكاديميات الخاصه
بنشر هذه الثقافه ان الذكاء الاصطناعي لن
ياخذ مكانك بل بالعكس احنا ممكن بشكل كبير
جدا
نستخدم هذه البيانات وهذه التقارير وهذه
التحاليل وهذه التصميمات الموجوده الجديده
في نمو الاعمال لدينا في تسويق منتجاتنا
في تغيير بيئه العمل لدينا في حلول جديده
في كل الملفات التي
يشهدها التغيرات
التكنولوجيه واليوميه اذا اعتقد ان هذه
التقنيات ستكون مكمله وليست معاوضه
للانسان وهنا سؤال دكتور انس قد يقول
البعض بانها او قد يخاف البعض مخاوفه قد
تكون مشروعه يعني هناك حتى مظاهرات خرجت
يعني مش مظاهرات كبيره ولكن متفرقه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مجموعه من
كتاب السناري بعد اطلاعهم على سونار كتب
بطريقه جيده جدا ممتازه
فخرجوا لانهم امتعظوا من امكانيه ان يكون
هناك او تكون هناك اله قادره على ان
تعوضهم محالتك وحضرتك تعلم بانه السيناريس
الجيد قلما يتواجد في الاوساط عموما
سينمائيه فهذه المخاوف لديها مؤشرات يمكن
ان نحضر فعلا اصطناعي يعني انا برايي
الشخصي فعلا هنالك محاذير كبيره يعني ادعم
ذلك
بالكثير من التقارير والكثير من
الاحصائيات وايضا من خلال الشركات الكبرى
شركه اي بي ام هي صرحت خلال الخمس سنوات
القادمه سوف نقلص اعداد الموظفين عنا 30%
وهي شركات ضخمه تكنولوجيه رقميه هي تدرك
وهي تعلم انه الكثير من المهمات اليدويه
والتي يمكن فعليا
الاستغناء عن الانسان من خلال الاله سوف
فعلا تحدث لماذا نحن نحن الان في عصر
السرعه والكل يتحرك بشكل كبير نحو ما يسمى
بالكفاءه والفعاليه وبالتالي هذا المطلوب
عنصر السرعه مطلوب ليس فقط على سيناريست
الذي يكتب النصوص ولكن صحيح ولكن حتى على
ان نذكر على سبيل المثال
الاعمال الفنيه الصور الفيديوهات الان
استطيع ان ان اقدم لك دوره تعليميه ومنهاج
علمي يعني اقوم متكامل في خلال ساعات
بسيطه او كنا في الاول يعني في مجال
الاكاديميه وفي مجال التعليم يعني هذا عمل
مدني يحتاج الى شهور ويحتاج الى او وقت
طويل الان جمع المعلومه وعمليه ترتيب
الافكار وعمليه الصناعه المحتوى اصبحت
اسرع ولكن لا نستطيع ان نقول الان الاله
بالمئه سوف تلغي نحتاج الانسان من اجل
التاكيد والتحقق من دقه المعلومات ولكن
باعداد اقل بكثير مما هو عليه قبل الذكاء
الاصطناعي هذا فيما يخص ايجابيه وسلبيه
اذا كان الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
وبالخصوص ولكن دكتور ايمن اليوم هل يمكن
تحديد اطار قانوني فعلا للتحكم بمثل هكذا
تقنيات هل يمكن وضع اطار قانوني لضبط
طريقه التعامل مع مثلا تعتقد الاتحاد
الاوروبي اقترح ذلك وهو يسعى لطرح مثل
هكذا فكره
البرلمان والكونجرس يدرس الان هذا الملف
تحديدا لاننا امام تحدي جديد امام تشريعات
جديده لم نكن نتوقعها من قبل اعتقد ايضا
ان الوطن العربي سيناقش هذا الملف لان زي
ما احنا بنقول زي ما التكنولوجيا لها
مزايا والتكنولوجيا دي من صنع الانسان
يعني لازم نبقى احنا متاكدين ان
التكنولوجيا اللي صنعها الانسان اللي
برمجها الانسان اللي عمل السياره
السياره اللي احنا بنقول عليها سياره
الكهربائيه والسياره الذكيه والسيارات هو
اللي عملها الانسان هو عملها الانسان ليه
عشان يساعد ويسهل على نفسه عشان نقلل من
التكلفه عشان نقلل من الوقت والمجهود اللي
بيحصل اذا ده اللي حصل عندما تم استخدام
الحاسب الالي لاول مره يمكن في بدايه
اواخر التميمينات في هذا العصر كان
الانسان يشكو ان الحاسب الالي هياخد مكانه
اذا يجب ان يكون هناك تشريعات تاخذ الجانب
الاجتماعي تاخذ الجانب الاقتصادي هل ده
هياثر علي كدخل هل ده هيقدر يتحكم في
الامور الاجتماعيه عندي ويمكن بدانا نشوف
ان في بعض الناس ابتدت تشتكي ان شات
ابتدى ياثر على حياتهم الاجتماعيه وابتدت
بعض الزوجات تاخذ هذا كصديق لها وبدا ان
هو يرشدها في بعض الملفات وبعض الامور اذا
نحن يجب ان يكون لدينا ولكن خلينا نبقى في
اطار تقنين هذه التقنيه دكتور انس سيقول
البعض بانه تويتر انستقرام فيسبوك ان لم
تتمكن القوانين من ضبطها على الاقل فكيف
سيتمكن القانون من ظبط مثل هكذا تقنيه
ساقتهم
تطور وتقدم اتفق معك مئه بالمئه في صراحه
دائما التقنيات الحديثه تتطور بشكل سريع
وتحدث تغييرات ايجابيه اكيد وسلبيه بنفس
الوقت من ثم تاتي في المرحله متاخره جدا
المشرعين ليقوموا بوضع ضوابط وقوانين وفي
اغلب الاحوال تكون هذه متاخره جدا لكن ما
نشهده الان تحديدا على تقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي مثل تشات وغيرها انها
تطورت بشكل سريع جدا يعني اقل في بضعه
اشهر
واحدث التغيرات كبيره جدا بسرعه لتفوق
ايضا ما شاهدناه من تقنيات سابقه في بضعه
ايام اصبح عدد المستخدمين بالملايين
وهذا صعب جدا ان يعني ندركه باليات ضبط
تشريعيه فعاله بشكل سريع ففعلا الان في في
جميع المؤسسات وفي جميع مراكز الاستشراف
والحوكمه في العالم هي في حاله طوارئ
طوارئ فعليا لوضع وسن ما يسمى او تعليمات
استرشاديه وايضا ضوابط كيف نستخدم هذه
التقنيات بشكل اخلاقي على الاقل لا يتضارب
مع يعني القيم العالميه الانسانيه وبشكل
يعني قد لا يكون يتعارض مع القوانين
الاتحاد الاوروبي تحديدا عنده مشكله او ما
يسمى بالخصوصيه والذكاء الاصطناعي حتى في
مارس كانت هناك مشكله فيما يخص حتى يعمل
الذكاء الاصطناعيه يجب ان يتغذى بكثير من
المعلومات وهذه المعلومات قد تكون عمليه
جلبها وعمليه اخذها شكل غير قانوني
يقول بانه تطور ومتقدم لدرجه انه قادر ان
يلتف على القوانين لا اعلم كيف ولكن هناك
مقال طرحته احدى الصحف البريطانيه طلعت
عليه وتحدث بانه هذا الذكاء الاصطناعي
بالتحديد قد يفوز وقد يلتف على كيف يفكر
الانسان هل هذا وارد هذا مخيف على فكره
طبعا الكثير من الاختبارات التي قدمت على
الشات بانه تم وضعهم في امتحانات
المحاماه وفعلا حصل على العلامات عاليه
يعني في اجتاز الكثير من الاختبارات
المعياريه العالميه وهذا يدل فعلا على
اتقانه وتحكمه
بالكتله العلميه الحاليه وقدرته ايضا في
الاستنباط والتحليل
وكشف النقاط الخلل والضعف الان في مجال
البرمجه يعني نستطيع ان نكتب الاف من يعني
البرامج ويستطيع بسرعه اكتشاف اي خلل او
اي خطا وهذا طبعا سوف يقلب الطاوله على
المبرمجين وليس فقط على جانب اول شكرك
جزيلا الشكر موضوع دائما يطرح
في نشراتنا
الدكتور انس النجداوي على اكاديميه
المستشار في اداره الاعمال الرقميه وتقنيه
ومن القاهره الدكتور ايمن الدهشان استشاري
المواد البشريه شكرا جزيلا لكما السلام
عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات